while we wait for gales one-on-one
interview with speaker Ryan Washington
is feeling the aftershocks from his
plans to retire Ryan says he will give
up his powerful position to spend more
time with his family the move sets up a
battle for House GOP control between
Majority Leader Kevin McCarthy and
Majority Whip Steve Scalise Ryan's two
top lieutenants Nancy cortices on
Capitol Hill to give us the lowdown
Nancy good morning good morning
Republicans worry that that leadership
scramble that lasts potentially for
months could be a big distraction they
also worry that Ryan's announcement
sends a signal both internally and to
the public that GOP leaders are already
anticipating that Democrats will win
back the house in November you all know
that I did not seek this job it's hard
to keep secrets on Capitol Hill but
Ryan's decision we've stunned his GOP
colleagues if I am here for one more
term my kids will only have ever known
me as a weekend dad the speaker tried to
tap down concerns that he'll be less
effective as a remain duck I intend to
run through the tape to finish the year
House Republicans expect two of Ryan's
deputies to spend the next half year
vying for his job California's Kevin
McCarthy and Louisiana's Steve Scalise I
do think that there is a leadership race
that probably started a few weeks ago
and that will pick up steam sources say
Ryan his wife and their three teenage
children had been mulling this move
since late last year and they've got
plenty of company 23 other House
Republicans a record have also announced
they're retiring in advance of what
polls indicate could be tough midterm
elections for the party in power I
believe each member is gonna be running
in their district
pretty damn toxic environment
Pennsylvania's Charlie dent is one of
those getting out it's gonna be
referendum on the president noted states
whose conduct in office it's not about
Paul Ryan but Ryan's decision could have
a ripple effect according to CBS news
director of elections and surveys
Anthony selves on toe I think the
biggest impact this might have is if it
encourages other Republicans to retire
if it does that opens up House seats and
it's always easier for the Democrats to
beat a newcomer than it is to beat an
incumbent and those retirements could
become the president's problem if
Republicans lose control of the house it
will be much more difficult for him to
push through his agenda the president
did wish Ryan well yesterday but viana
he never truly got over some of Ryan's
criticism of him during the campaign no
he did not we were looking forward to
hearing from the speaker in the next
hour Nancy thank you